the young people that's watching all
over the world
when you look at Kevin Gates be inspired
by my greatness but also understand that
I'm not Superman I'm not a God I'm only
a human being so I do have character
flaws I do make mistakes
I promise that I continue to be as
honest as possible with you for the rest
of my life or for as long as I'm here I
love you all people want to tell you
that I want to kick you when you're down
I ain't been and I ain't breaking I
ain't fooling we do not surrender we do
not Retreat we live by this we die by
this stand on what you believe in and
when you stand for what you believe in
you accept whatever come behind it I'm
not allowing nothing to distract me
right now for me I gotta focus on me it
ain't that I'm giving so much of myself
I'm really venting because I don't have
no therapist so the microphone is my
therapist and I noticed that through
people watching me heal they're learning
how to heal themselves in their own ways
so is that it's relatable because
there's so many men and women that
suffer from the same that I'm suffering
from her people her people man I'm just
saying about that I'm destroying on the
inside right now and I don't know why
people like to walk around and say
everything just great that's a lie I
woke up a straight Grouch this morning
but guess what I did think to make
myself feel good I did things to make
myself feel good I put positive energy
into myself
so that when I come here I wouldn't
project negativity into the universe
because anything that one person do we
all feel it it affects everybody see
when you get by yourself sometimes the
thoughts be so loud you you can't even
stand your own self it could trick your
mind but you can't trick your heart so I
operate out of the hard chakra out of
love so anybody I meet I'm gonna greet
them with love and humility no ego I'm
not here to compete with nobody I'm just
here to get what I could get and when I
say get what I could get it be the
situations you walk into
that seemed like nothing gonna come out
of it but it'd be the most refreshing
the most rejuvenating you ever had a
conversation with somebody you felt
drained after absolutely you ever had a
conversation with somebody you feel
energized after yeah because it was
positive energy so you never know what
gems you're gonna get it's a journey
yeah it's like a treasure hunt with me
I'm just picking up little pieces along
the way see I'm in tune with myself now
and I'm getting more and more in tune
with myself this is a relationship we
getting to know each other me myself and
I so I'm in a beautiful relationship
with myself I learned different things
about myself every day I go off of
what's good for the soul there's two
type of people on earth I don't get off
into what race you are because it don't
matter it's real people and fake people
how you know real people from fake
people real people do real things fake
people do fake I I can't judge nobody
because I don't know what my blessing
gonna come from it be the people you
least expect that give you your biggest
blessings so I don't judge nobody
everybody deal with their depression
differently I used to deal with mine
with pacifiers entertainment drugs like
you just do everything
and we feel like this normal we
normalized it because I didn't want to
deal with the issue I was suppressing
but now I deal with the issue you got to
feel it to hear that I go back and
revisit the situation I see how it made
me feel because anything that ever
happened to me in my life was a great
teacher whether good or bad so I go back
and I put a positive affirmation to it
what good came from this situation
because I used to hold a lot of
resentment about me being locked up in
2016 I'm like man I took everything from
me nah that wouldn't happen this
couldn't be taking place I'm thankful
for that situation though and the most
blessings I get the more humble it make
me God keep me humble so I never had to
be humbled again and the beautiful thing
about Kevin Gates is the world got to
see me go from
being one of the most low vibrational on
drugs people on Earth Watching Me
come home out of prison fat aggressive
miserable watching me just turn my life
around my transformation it's beautiful
sometimes when I look at old pictures of
myself I'd be like damn I used to be
that person I'm on my mission I know my
mission and I fell in love with that
mission I see what my mission is I'm
doing it right now
I ain't want to come do this but it's
the things that you don't want to do and
be the best things for you the days I
don't want to go to the gym that's the
days I have my best workout and I train
myself to be like that now because we
are creatures of habit I'm tired I'ma
lay down no you're not tired do
something to give yourself energy
because it's the food that we eat that
make us tired I'm out here every day
it's a blessing like you you were only
victim of the energy that you project
when I move I move with love I move I'm
peaceful and humble at all costs
but no surrender no retreat we walk with
those who walk with us have you ever
heard of the term an emotional detox I
just discovered this on my journey you
know most of the emotions that we go
through like traumas and life is a
journal now to thank the nation most of
the traumas that we go through we Harbor
in our gut I never knew this
we Haul the emotions and our gut that's
our first brain is the CPU central
processing unit for the body and it's
certain yoga poses and yoga stretches
that I do that I was in I was in one of
these poses called a pigeon pole and I
just started crying let's never taught
his children how to detox emotionally
forever like I wouldn't even been able
to come in here and be like vulnerable
it take more strength to be vulnerable
than anything on my journey with having
these emotional detoxes it allowed me to
really process my emotions in the right
manner see I'm not too hard for myself
like that's a car with his act and the
worst thing a man could be is a coward
to his own self I don't care about what
nobody think about me or what nobody say
I live life every day you looking at my
life for your source of entertainment my
life is not your Source entertainment
last time I checked I'm grown either you
love me or you don't the people that
hurt me the most
is my own people they they hurt me the
most been my own people people that look
like me like it's a lot of Muslims that
love me but there's also a lot of
Muslims that judge me you can't have
tattoos that's Haram this this that
Haram that means forbidden you can't do
this and this man you know who helped me
like really get back on my feet since my
last tour it been Jews and transgenders
like the people that the world would say
is the worst people them the people that
helped me like I'm doing business they
bring like I got a Pioneer Jew he
bringing me coffee deals and all of this
we doing all these Investments this lady
she a transgender she say baby you can
use my warehouse if you want to put all
your Merchant up just gave me the
warehouse man the words you say they
speak to my spirit I love who I love who
you all love what you stand for it be
the people that the world say is the
most worst people people on earth been
the people that help me and it's my own
people that judge me and kick me when
I'm down and I always got something
negative to say about me always in my
business keep my name and Miss like like
didn't they say black lives matter I
don't get mad when I don't support it
who they matter to we kill each other
all day
who they matter till we talk behind each
other back we always but like
sometimes when you forgive people it's
not to rectify the AFL or get the matter
resolved it's to resolve the matter
internally I'm forgiving you for me not
for you I'll probably never deal with
you again but I forgive you but it just
showed me I can't be looking for myself
inside of other people and we do that a
lot of times I can't expect you to be
the way I'm built because I'm cut from a
bandana a lot of these dudes cut paper
so I can't expect you to be like me and
I understand that and I respect it I
just know how far to go with you know
trusting people is scary
say what you want about me I don't even
entertaining I wasn't made for everybody
to like it it ain't been a time that I
wasn't scared or I didn't how I feel
it's okay to have feelings but I operate
and I face that field with bravery I'm
gonna preach to you with my actions when
I utter with my mouth my actions must
prove and the greatest teachers teach
what I was speaking
and that's just always been my
philosophy because I'm still learning
and one of my biggest lessons is I'm
learning to love the stranger that was
once myself like my mind don't even
think prison because I've mastered that
in the facility I go to I'm going to be
in a leadership position because I know
how to do that that's not nothing that's
that's Child's Play to me the hardest
thing is to can you come out here from
nothing
and be greater than what you was before
this is the first time I could say I've
been proud of myself a lot of my results
came from um beating myself up being
hard on myself that was a way of like um
dealing and working through like a
traumatic past and I just got to the
point where I'm able to laugh at myself
I'm back able to stand up and do it from
a standing position you know you do it
on your knees but I'm able to stand up I
was doing that first but I had kind of
ripped one of my ab muscles my body
wasn't ready I was doing it prematurely
so now I'm to the point where I could do
it like standing up and when I was doing
it at the gym
I had kind of like slipped a little bit
and I laughed at myself yeah it's so
good to be able to laugh at myself and
not be embarrassed and not care about
what other people think so for the first
time I really been like happy and I've
been I've been cautious of what I speak
to myself
Muhammad Ali I'm gonna show you how
great I am he suffered
they made it hard for him but he smiled
he found a way to smile through it all
yeah he suffered he died doing what he
loved and I had really had put it in my
mind like this music I love it I'm gonna
die for it but when you live in your
spirit and in truth you make all of the
wrong people uncomfortable anyway
hey I wasn't made for everybody to like
once you change your perspective that's
when miracles happen it was a blessing
for me because I gained a greater
understanding of myself I don't have to
engage with the world I create my own
world around me doing better doing what
I used to be doing because this is a
continuous Journey like it ain't never
gonna stop like it don't I might have a
bad day tomorrow I might say ah you go
crazy but we still gonna keep going I
got 10 people healing is a journey you
don't just heal in one session you gotta
always put in the work like I ain't
supposed to be sitting here keep myself
inventory while I'm talking to you but I
do that because I got to because I'm
human and I don't judge people because I
know I ain't got no room to judge nobody
Kevin Gates says things that people are
afraid to say we just think less of
ourselves but I had made a bottom myself
I never do no more negative self-talk I
never doubt myself beat myself up for
past mistakes and what's been helping me
when I do myself inventory checks like
any mistake like you ever made a mistake
and you think back and you kind of
cringe like man I should have did your
spirit is a hurry to hold it out of 5
billion sperms you was the one that made
it and if you stop evolving then you die
yeah you got to keep growing you got to
keep growing if you stay stagnant you
you stop growing and anything not
growing is dead when you leave the only
thing that'd be left the only thing left
that you leave behind is your name I'd
rather a good name over multiple riches
and things of that nature best things in
life are really free it's just it's once
we change our perspective that's when
Miracles really start to happen in our
lives I believe that a man should take
responsibility for the action I believe
that whatever happened with me I'm gonna
take my responsibility for it and we're
gonna get it done whatever I got to go
through come on because this ain't gonna
be the first struggle or the last one
that I go through my life has been
constant struggle that's all it's been
and I Prevail because I'm persistent and
I don't stop and I don't get tired of
going hard for what I believe in the
word love is a misspelled word for
unemployed emotion you got to show me
you love me
you can't tell me you gotta show me this
this new trend now this alpha male this
alpha female going on and it seems
like they competing with each other but
man it's not supposed to go like that
it's the holy divine feminine energy and
sacred masculinity together as one we we
balance each other out Mother Earth
father sky that we work together you
know because I went through that I'm
hurt man I I was dying on the inside but
guess what I worked through it
I worked through that I'm not about to
judge everybody based on one bad
experience I'm gonna take my time in
here and then when I'm ready when I'm
ready for the world I'm ready for the
world again I believe communication is
what keeps the marriage together
communication love trust honor respect
like you respecting your partner when
you start in titles I don't like titles
when you do that husband and wife
you got to live up to the title
it's a friendship it's a bond and that's
the loyalty and things of that nature
but I also say this you got to be loyal
to yourself first also can't obligate
yourself to a false cause a lot of
people a lot of men we as men as being
providers A Lot oftentimes we do that
so My Philosophy is this I'm not here to
give marriage advice I tell people
either you grow together or you grow
apart that's it once you stop growing
together it's over with
I don't think you could ever be
recountable because y'all on two
different Journeys now it may come back
around at the end but like I say I'm not
here to tell people stay stay together
and stick it out I'm not I'm not an
advocate of that I haven't seen a lot of
people suffer in silence especially me
especially me and I've seen a lot of men
suffer inside without being tested you
never know your true strength or your
true Inner Strength whether it be
psychological
and physically or emotionally you gotta
tense yourself and always push yourself
so you know how you're truly strong you
really are